hi everyone welcome to another edition
of youtube developers live my name is e
chi lan and today we're going to be
talking about how to keep up to date on
the Java API client library so those of
you who have been following the show
will know that we have moved our samples
away from code google com to github com
so why don't we go and switch to my
computer now if you're going to
code.google.com / p / youtube data api
dash samples hopefully you're seeing a
warning that says hey we move to github
check us out and this is what are some
of our github samples look like and this
is right here that's a Java sample this
is the right page you should be looking
at so if we click through to the Java
sample one thing that you usually want
to keep up to date if you want to keep
up to date with new API s is the version
of the Java API client is using so one
way you can do this is by looking in
maven and looking at pom.xml and I'm
going to blow this up real quick you'll
see that there's a youtube version and a
YouTube analytics version and this is a
really good way to make sure that you
download code that will definitely work
is by copying the samples but what if
we're not always keeping the samples up
to date what if we release a new API and
the samples they might lag a few days
but you need that API right away how do
you know what the newest version of the
API client library is well it's not on
the Java code samples page but there's a
there's a page we have on developers
google com for the api client libraries
this is the api client library home and
you can get here by going to
developers.google.com api dash client
dash library and again you can always
search for this in your favorite search
engine and we'll take to this page and
what you want to do is you want to click
through the java
supported Google API s let's scroll all
the way down and you'll see that there's
the YouTube analytics API as well as a
data API so I'm going to go ahead and
open these in a new tab okay so I'm on a
data API client for java i'm going to
scroll down and you can download the
client library but usually the best way
is probably the use of builds is like
maven or Gradle because there's lots of
dependencies that library depends on so
click on a maven tab and you'll see what
the palm configuration is so palm that
XML configuration is now we look here
it's rev 79 1 dash 17 dash oh good our
samples up to date on that now let's
just make sure analytics API samples
also up-to-date click on maven it's rev
24 1.17 24 1.17 good so this means that
all of our samples are currently up to
date and again as you watching the show
there's probably going to be a newer
version of the API client libraries out
don't copy these exact numbers instead
you should go to developers.googl calm
api dash client libraries / java and
this will be the right place to look for
what the most current version is and
this is only something you have to do if
you're using a statically typed language
such as Java if you're using a language
such as excuse me Python or Ruby you
don't need to do this the python library
automatically generates the api document
it automatically generates the methods
that you use to make API calls so you
won't need to keep as up to date but do
check periodically for major releases
okay well that's all i have for you guys
today thank you for tuning in for this
very short show just want to share some
tricks with you for all the other fellow
java developers out there all right take
care and have a great day